to always make the words that
he said as impactful as
possible while at the same time
being appropriate.
this chapter here that we're
going to discuss is regarding
or the chapters to come is
regarding various things that
the prophet would say in
certain on certain occasions.
So, when he would enter his
house, when he would leave his
house, when he would, when the
would be made, how the should
be made, and so forth. Now, I'd
to mention something
before we proceed And that is
that words are very, very
impactful. They have a huge
impact on the listener. we kind
of live in a time We live in a
time over overcome with level.
We live in a time that is
bombarded with and enveloped in
level which is idle talk, idle
speech. Just saying things all
of the time, talking, just a
chatty Cathy. not really
saying anything to mean
anything particularly. Just
talking for the sake of
talking. Not worrying about
what we say and we have this
feeling that the things that we
say don't really have very big
impact on those who are
listening and furthermore, even
if they do, we can always just
say sorry, right? This is the
idea. It's kind of funny
because
You know what the literal
translation of the word is?
Literal translation. You know a
level in the Quran, right?
We've heard of a level.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
described the believers.
Describe the people eligible
for the highest places of
paradise he said. Those who
refrain and
avoid They avoid the level. A
level in the Quran is any
speech or action that has no
positive impact that has no
positive result to it or
affect, right? That is a level.
A level is not just what you
say. Allah was also what you
do. Not speaking about a level
a level in the Quran is not
something that is speech or
action that is haram. That's
different. Is just speech or
action that has that is of no
consequence. Right? It's not
bad but it's not good. It's
just it's just you know, it's
just action or speech that is
idle, right? The literal
translation, of
in the English language. We
were to translate level in
English It translates to
Twitter. That's actually true.
Yeah. It translates to Twitter.
You know what level is? Level
in the Arabic language is the
sound of birds. The Arabs are
referred to the sound of birds
as a level. Right? It will say
the birds tell who.
In the sound chirping of birds.
The Twitter of birds. Right?
The literal translation of
level is Twitter. So, we are
enveloped in a society that is
full of just meaningless,
mindless chatter that pollutes
the mind, pollutes the heart,
and waste time in an
unimaginable way. You know,
we're always speaking about you
know, these kind of woke
westerners we have to make sure
that we don't waste earth's
resources, right? And we're so
wasteful and yada yada yada,
right? But when it comes to
time we take pride in wasting
it. We take pride in wasting
that resource.
a level that we live in. A lot
of people you ask or if they
ask themselves, why why don't I
read the Quran? Why don't know
Arabic? Why don't I know
Arabic? Well, I I I don't have
a good teacher. Well, why did
why don't you find a good
teacher? Well, I really don't
have time. you have time. We
all have time, right? The issue
is we don't want to make time.
Why don't we want to make it
For various reasons. One of the
biggest reasons that we don't
want to make time is because
we're afraid of what we are
going to have to face when we
come face to face with the
Quran. It's a very frightening
book, right? It's a
mirror. You look into it and
you see exactly your
description there. Exactly what
you should be and exactly what
you should not be and when you
me the Quran's meanings. It
demands change. And we
inherently are afraid of
change. It scares us. We're
comfortable the way we are. And
we don't want anything to
change or rock the boat. Right?
So this issue of you know we
don't have time. We have plenty
of time. We have so much time.
That we don't know what to do
with it. Everybody is kind of
you know if you wish if if a
person could wish, if I could
wish, you know, anything. A lot
of people, most people would
wish for. More time. I want to
live longer. I want, I wish I
had more time but if in
reality, if we all had more
time, we wouldn't know what to
do with it. We're mishandling
the time that we have now.
and so a lot of this issue of
time and this is going to tie
in to the chapters that we are
in right now with regards to
words and speech. This is a
very big thing. It's very
important. We'll discuss why
it's so crucial and important
inshallah. I want everyone to
kind of imagine with me the
time of the prophet in your
mind's eye imagine yourself
living in that time. Okay? What
was it to live in that
time? Well, a lot of the houses
were made out of mud, right?
And a house or a home actually
was just basically one room.
That was the home, right? There
were, there were no bathrooms,
there were no sinks, there were
no kitchens. It's just that one
room. We keep that room clean.
We sleep in it. We have company
and guests into that room. We
cook there. We meet there. We
cry there. We laugh together
there. All everything is
happening in this one room.
Okay? and this one room has a
roof. A lot of times the roofs
were actually leaves and
branches from date palms that
they would place on top of it.
and when it would rain really
really hard or not even that
hard, it would start to eat
away at your home. It would
start to corrode it. So, after
a rainstorm, you have to go out
and fix it, right? Get the mud
together and put your house
back together essentially.
water was found in a well. The
well is shared by the entirety
of the community. Everyone
shares this one well. And so
we're having hundreds of people
flock to this well. Every day.
To get an essential amount of
water to drink, cook, clean,
make wudu, bathe, all of these
other things. Now, the well is
kind of a big hole in the
ground. And at most if it's a
very big well, you're going to
have two or three people who
are putting their buckets into
this well at once. So, can you
imagine standing in a line or
hours every day just to draw a
few buckets of water to take to
your house? That's just to get
started. So, you can just have
something to drink for the day,
right? On top of that, people
that are coming to this well,
they're bringing all of their,
all of their camels, and their
sheep, and everything else to
come and drink from this well.
We have to wait. Now, if you
understand that and you
understand that you could very
possibly be there for five or 6
hours, right? We understand why
it was so important, what Musa
did, Alaihi Salam, when the two
girls were standing aside
waiting for their turn. Like,
why is that such a big thing?
So, let them wait and you know,
five, 10 minutes. This is not a
fast food restaurant. They
could have been there till
night fall. They could have
been there until the night. And
so when he did that, even
though he was exhausted, it was
something worthy of Allah
mentioning in the Quran, right?
So, that's the situation with
water. Let's think about the
situation with having to
relieve yourself. Go to the
bathroom. Well, there weren't
any privis. There weren't any
stalls to use the bathroom.
People didn't have restrooms in
their home. You would have to
walk to areas that were known
as El Rawait, right? And in the
Arabic language, is the area
where people would usually go
to relieve themselves? So,
you'd have to walk for maybe a
quarter mile or maybe half a
mile to get out there, to just
relieve yourself with some
semblance of privacy. You have
to go two or three times a day
or if you have a bladder
problem or something. If you're
sick and have some kind of
diarrhea, you're going to be
going back and forth all day.
That's just to use the restroom
to relieve yourself. How long
would it take to walk a quarter
mile back and forth just to
relieve a person's self? Maybe
half an hour? Maybe 45 minutes?
Just to get some water You're
spending two, three, four hours
at the well every day. Then, we
have to feed our livestock,
right? Because that's our
livelihood. So, we have to take
our herd when ever it is and
take it out somewhere far where
there's some kind of vegetation
for them to graze and if
anyone's ever
been around herds of sheep or
goats or what have you and they
graze. It takes four, five, 6
hours. Sometimes, people will
spend all day with them because
they're they they don't get
full. And you have to walk back
and forth with these things.
tilling in the ground and the
earth just to grow something.
There weren't any big heavy
machines If a person have five
or 10 acres of farmland, they
have to till all of that by
hand They have to plant all of
that by hand and they have to
weed it by hand and they have
to water it by hand, right? If
a person wants to go to the
market, Most people walked at
that time. You were considered
somewhat wealthy if you had a
mule to ride on. or very
wealthy if you had a camel or
if you had a horse then you're
considered a fetish. You're
considered a a knight. A person
that is able to go to war. Only
for sin had horses. Right? you
might walk two, three miles to
get to the marketplace go and
sell whatever you're trying to
sell or barter or buy something
you're trying to buy. In the
midst of all of this, we're
still kind of imagining the
prophet environment In the
midst of all of this, We have
issues of illness simple things
that we have today could kill a
person very easily back then.
We have issues of traveling. We
jump in our car. We go drive
fifty, 60 miles, 200 miles, and
come back in a few hours. This
were two and three and four-day
long trips just to go to the
edge of the Medina and come
back. Right? There wasn't any
transportation. There weren't
any cellphones if you needed to
say something to someone. You
needed to go there physically
or send someone. Can you
imagine how much time, how time
consuming it is just to live
with the essentials during that
time. Just to have water, how
much time you have to invest to
get that water. Just to bathe.
Just to bathe. If it's cold
out, you have to build a fire
and you have to then heat this
water up and then you have to
bathe and then you have to,
right? If you want to wash some
clothes, you're not throwing
them in the the washer with
some tide. You have to sit
there and scrub these clothes
physically and you have to hang
them and you have to fold them
and all of these things, right?
So, your entire day is consumed
in doing what? What we do today
in our time in about 20
minutes? Think about it. When
you wake up, you go, you take a
shower, you use the bathroom,
you brush your teeth, you drink
a glass of water, you have
breakfast, you do your laundry
or put in a load of laundry.
You did all that in twenty, 30
minutes. That used to take a
day or two back then. Yet, in
spite of that, the companions
were somehow able to go for war
and they were able to make
salah in the Masjid. Every
single salah, a single salah
might take up to an hour, an
hour and a half. They were able
to make time for that. They
were able to memorize the
Quran. They were able to spend
time with the prophet they were
able to be there for they were
able to visit their their
relatives. They were able to do
all of these things even though
just to get the essentials of
life that we have today. It
would take them hours upon
hours. Just to make a little
trip to another village and
come back might be a two-week
thing. So, people kind of
imagine that the prophet and
his companions, you know, they
didn't really have much
responsibilities. I mean, what?
They just had a few cows or a
few sheep and they were just
kind of, you know, they didn't
have much to do but today,
we've got so much going on, you
know? So, they could make time
but we're just so busy. It
couldn't be more incorrect. It
couldn't be more opposite. we
are
comparatively the most non-busy
people compared to them. I
mean, these people were doing
everything that they did to
survive and in top of all this,
they have to make time to
practice with their spears or
get their military ready or go
and collect the from all of the
different villages or they had
to you know, maintain all of
these things that they were
doing. Imagine the
responsibilities that the
prophet had. From the minute he
opens his eyes until he's
sleeping and even while he's
sleeping, he is either
receiving from Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala or he is giving to
people. People are asking him.
People are seeking advice.
People have issues. People are
looking up to him. People are
waiting for him to lead salah.
They're waiting for him to tell
them what to do. They're
waiting for him. When he goes
home, his his wives are waiting
for him to to deal with their
situations. He has a whole
bunch of children. He has all.
Could you imagine how much
responsibilities he had? Yet,
these men and women were able
to make time. And so the
question is, when we say, well,
I don't really have the time,
is that really true? Do we
really not have the time? Or if
we were to time, it would take
away a half hour from the seven
hours we spend on average
watching TV. Is that what the
issue is? Or is the issue that
I might have to, you know,
sacrifice sleeping, a nice
whole 12 hours a day. Or is it
that I might have to not play
as much PlayStation or am I not
I might have to cut down on the
card games after a show or I
might have to watch a little
less football or I might have
to. We have time The honest
truth is that if a person spent
a half hour a night. Just a
half hour. Concentrated half
hour every night within a month
they can read the Quran. They
can read the Quran. And if they
do that for five years, they
will understand the majority of
what they read. And if they do
that for 10 years, they will
have memorized the entirety of
the Quran. If we are to just
memorize one verse a day in 10
years time, everyone of us
would be a half of of the
Quran. we have time We don't
have to go to a well. We just
turn the faucet on. We don't
have to cool water in in
pottery. We just have plug the
fridge in, right? We don't have
to heat water up to take a
shower. We just turn turn the
knob in the shower and we have
a nice shower and we've got all
these different kinds of
showers and you know, showers
that massage you and showers
that vibrate you and showers
that you know, spa showers and
hot tubs and all of this stuff,
right?
I mean, we can't even imagine
what it would be to eat
the same thing for more than
three days in a row. Imagine
with me if you ate the same
thing every day for 3 days.
Most of us have never done
that. But the prophet and his
companions have spent up to six
months eating nothing but dates
and water. 6 months. Right? So
we have the time. We just we're
just not making the time. And
one of the things that makes us
feel we are crunched for
time and hard pressed for it is
the amount of level that is in
our, that is in our
environment. The amount of idle
talk, idle, speech, idle,
action that is in our
environment. The amount of time
that we spend on level, right?
You turn on the TV, you have
these news flashes and
information is just dumped on
you everywhere you look. An
advertisement after
advertisement. All it's saying
to you is obey, consume, obey,
consume, don't question,
consume. That's what we're
being taught day and night. and
so our environment is totally
full and saturated with this
level to the point where I can
say this and I can say this
honestly. Think to yourself,
when is the last time you spent
a solid hour just thinking?
Honestly, when is the last time
you spent one solid hour just
thinking Do you even remember
what your own voice sounds
like? I mean, we are constantly
being flooded with other
people's opinions, with other
people's voices, with other
people, with with
advertisements and telling us
what to wear and what to eat
and what to drink, and if you
drink this, your life is
going to be great and if you
don't, well, it's not going to
be that great and if you buy
this vacuum, it's going to be
awesome and a TV with 500
channels and you know, clothing
with different people's names
on it, and so on and so forth.
It's just hyper consumer just
eat, eat, eat. That's it. so
that now, when is the last time
that we really sat down with
our own thoughts? Can we even
remember what our own thoughts
are? Can we even remember And
do we even know? Can we
distinguish in our minds?
Honestly, the difference
between my own produced
thoughts and the opinions of
others that I think are my own
thoughts but they're really
not. So, we have all this
information coming at us at
Bray Connect Speed and we have
no time to digest it. So, now,
we don't even just watch the
news. We watch the news and
then we have analysts come on
and tell us what should we
think about what we just heard?
As if what we think matters, it
doesn't change the price of tea
in China. Why does this matter
to me? Why is this important?
So this level that we are
saturated with, it's very
harmful. The prophet
used to seek refuge in a law
from
is to seek refuge in Allah from
knowledge that will not be of
consequence. Knowledge that
will not benefit.
Imagine knowledge that is
harmful. He's seeking refuge in
Allah from knowledge that has
no benefit, right? Why? What's
the harm if you know something
that won't hurt you? The answer
is, it's it pollutes your mind.
It pollutes your heart. It
gunks up your machinery. Your
cognitive abilities are going
to be less. Every time you
allow yourself to be subject to
things that are inconsequential
and we're not speaking about
things that are haram. Things
that are haram are far more
numerous than that which is
inconsequential now.
I mean, how many times have we
been fooled into this same
thing? Well, it's just a
two-minute video. It's just a
two-and-a-half-minute video and
before you know it's, you know,
four and a half hours have gone
by. Your face is red, you're
sweating, Your neck hurts, your
back hurts because you're
hunched over your phone for
four or five hours at a time.
So what we need to understand
is that words have effects.
It's not you know, sticks
and stones will break my bones
but words will never hurt me.
That's not true. Words have an
effect on people. Because words
are the communication of ideas
and beliefs. Whatever those
ideas and beliefs are. and so,
it's very important to learn
the skill of using words. Many
people know how to speak. Few
people know how to speak
properly And that is a skill
that you learn. And that skill
is that you think about what
you are going to say before you
say it. You analyze it. Before
you say something, you think to
yourself. Is this in itself
good? Is it true? Is it
correct? Am I sure of that? Is
what I'm going to say
appropriate? Cuz it may be true
may be correct. It's just not
appropriate It's just not the
appropriate place or time or
listener for that to be said.
and so, words have an effect We
live in a world that overuses
very powerful words, a very
fake world. We kind of live,
you know, we we live in a time
of fake, fake news, and fake
politics and fake food and and
and fake spirituality and fake
smiles and fake people and fake
physically fake people, right?
Artificial, most of everything
around us is artificial right?
Artificial news, artificial
problems, artificial solutions,
artificial food,
and so, when we live in a place
or a time of such superficial
existence, what ends up
happening is that we become
superficial, we become fake, we
join the club. It's going to
affect you. If you live in that
kind of society, no matter what
you do, you're going to be
affected somehow, someway. More
or less based on how much you
engage and allow yourself to
engage.
and in this kind of world that
we are living in now, you know,
a world of fake feelings, fake
problems, you know, people get
on the their webcam or their,
you know, livestream or
whatever it is and cry and pout
and about silly things. Most of
these people, this is actually
a fact. That Fema, we know
Fema, right? The Federal
Emergency Management
Sophie, huh. agency, yes.
Federal Emergency Management
Agency, right? They have
mentioned that if the
electricity alone were to go
out within 6 months, almost 70%
of the entire population would
die. 70% That's if we just lost
power for 6 months. I mean, a
lot of these people, these
influencers, and these, these
people have no jobs, they have
no skills. And they, they
aren't, they aren't no help to
humanity in any way. If we were
to lose power or society, we're
to somehow collapse partially
even. These people wouldn't
even know how to tie their own
shoes because there's not an
app that tells them how to do
it. They can't go to Wiki Howe
and and learn how to do it We
don't know how to build a fire.
We don't know how to cook. We
don't know how to clean. We
don't know how to do anything.
And so,
issue here is that we have come
to believe in this kind of
artificial society that
Words
are not really very
serious and very powerful words
the word love or the word
hate or the word sorry. These
are very powerful meanings,
right? We use it so much that
it means nothing anymore. So,
we think that we can say, you
know, whatever we want and then
say, well, I'm sorry if I hurt
you or if I was inappropriate
or if I lied or if I misled you
or all of these kind of fancy
words, that doesn't, that
doesn't erase what happened.
What happened happened and it
left a scar just your body
produces scar tissue when you
know, it is cut. Your the skin
produces scar tissue in its
place. Likewise, is the is the
mind. This is why things like
lying is haram even if you're
joking. Even if you're joking.
because when you tell someone a
lie as a joke, you you're lying
to them, right? And especially
children. I mean, that's a type
of child abuse. You know, when
you tell tell a child, scare a
child with something, you know?
Oh, you know, the boogeyman's
coming for you, you know, or or
your parents left you, or you,
you, you were actually adopted.
We're not your real parent.
These kind of jokes that people
play on their kids. That scars
them deeply. Because what
you've done is you've just
planted a seed in that person's
mind that I have the capacity
to lie and be dishonest. You
can't always trust me. And if
it's a child, that changes
their entire world view. For
their life to come. Words have
meanings. They are very very
serious things. Likewise, it is
haram in Islam, haram. To scare
a Muslim. right? to scare a
Muslim. You know, you jump out
and you scare em or you blow
some horn while they're
sleeping or you know, so on and
so forth. This is called
Muslim. This is haram in Islam.
And in the time of the prophet
the companions were travelling
and you know, they're riding
their animals and one of them
fellas while he was riding and
so some of his friends took one
of his ropes. You know, a rope
was a big thing back then. He
had to, it was cost money and
you know, and they took one of
his ropes and they made him
think that he had dropped it
while he was while he was
riding. It could be miles back
in the dark in the desert. You
know, it's gone. So, when he
woke up, he saw it, that he was
gone, and he started freaking
out. And then it was now
we have it. You know it's just
a joke. And the prophet
prohibited that. And prohibited
that a person does that.
and when you do something like
that, you articulate to the
subject that you have the
capacity to be deceptive. You
have the capacity to be
treacherous. Even if it's just
a joke, if it's a joke, it can
happen in real life. It can
happen when you're serious.
It's just a change of of
intention between joking and
serious. And so this is very
important for us to understand
as kind of a preface before we
get into the rest here. We see
that spends so much time pining
over every single narration.
Analyzing how the prophet said,
what he said, and even choosing
words. What kind of word should
I choose? Should I choose this
word or should I choose this
word when I say it? everything
that you say and everything
that you put out there in the
world has a real effect on
someone. And that person is
going to go on to have a real
effect on others. And an effect
on a person in this life is an
effect on a person in the
hereafter. In their eternity.
The words are very serious. And
learning the skill. And having
the skill and honing the skill
of
using words and being able to
articulate exactly what you
mean in an appropriate way,
that's actually a skill that
takes a very long time and a
lot of effort to learn and and
and master to be able to
express yourself. Many people
are unable to learn things
because they don't know how to
ask the right question. They
have a particular meaning in
their mind but when they go to
put it into words, they can put
it into words and half of
knowledge is knowing how to ask
the right question Knowing how
to put, put your, your, you
know, what you're looking for
into a proper question. That's
half of knowledge As the
scholars have mentioned. Half
of knowledge is knowing how to
ask a question properly. The
other half is learning how to
listen. That is what knowledge
is. That's how it's attained.
So, we've discussed before the
importance of vocabulary. We've
discussed before the importance
of learning as many words as a
person can learn and using
those words appropriately. This
is what eloquence is. Eloquence
is not using big words or fancy
words or very complex sentence
structures, eloquence, in its
essence, is using the right
words to convey the proper
meanings based on the listener.
That is what eloquence is. If a
person comes and talks a very
very fancy talk to a group of
middle schoolers and it goes
over their head. This person is
not considered eloquent.
They're not considered
articulate. This is very
inarticulate. Because an
articulate eloquent person is a
person who is able to look at
his listener and know what you
what words to use in order to
communicate exactly what is
intended. This is what
eloquence is. Right? This
what's known as in Arabic. Is
using the right words for the
right listener. And using the
right words for the right
meanings. And this is why we
hear things. Tell me if you if
these words don't sound
familiar. Sorry. I apologize.
That's not what I meant. The
prophet said,
He said, stay away from
anything that you will have to
explain to others after doing.
Anything that you say, anything
that you do, if you have to
later explain yourself, just
don't do it that way. Stay away
from anything that will force
you to have to explain yourself
Whether it be words or actions
or places where you're going to
be at or whatever it is.
Anything that force you to have
to explain yourself to others,
just stay clear of it.
our next chapters that we are
going to get into are chapters
regarding what the prophet
would say when he would enter
his house, how he would enter
his house, as well, how he
would eat, and the etiquettes
of eating, what he would say
and do and so forth. After
that, we will get into the
etiquettes of Assalam. And
initiating interactions with
others. Likewise to both
Muslims and non Muslims. We
will later get into chapters
regarding which is seeking
permission to enter a person's
home or interacting with people
in an appropriate way so as not
to impinge upon their privacy.
Likewise, the etiquettes of
traveling and continuing on to
the etiquettes of a person in
his own thoughts, right? This
is also a chapter that we will
get into. Along with other
chapters regarding words and
speech. So, that is enough for
tonight.
[Arabic recitation]